you're welcome to this video yeah this
is a let's video just like any other but
this is the first video that I'm
recording him after more than five weeks
off yeah I've been yeah on holiday
working away from home different things
and now I'm back recording Blitz videos
yeah well we had the videos every day
but this was all pre-recorded so now I'm
ready on with with new games so um this
is a king's indian and kind of a rare
line I mean it's age 3 but Bishop d3 is
kind of uncommon I think it still looks
like a fairly normal position yeah
g-form I was wondering about that move
maybe I can go h5 directly attack that
not giving him more time to solidify the
Kings side he probably has to go g5 now
that's that's the other move that was at
least term theoretically possible ok I
think I'm going to take and go night h7
trying to exploit those weaknesses on
the dark squares here like g5 and f form
would be nice to get in something like
Bishop f6 Bishop g5 this is what I'm
trying to do Oh dad s you may be queen
age three and that is this idea huh
and the age for a trial can get can get
tricky I'm definitely oh so this should
have 60 is that that's too risky and
might be risky you should have six
somebody there he goes night everyone
and I play Bishop g5 he's got queen age
3 NM I'm just busted hmm so that's
amazing okay so what what am I doing
here okay on Queen age three i still
have my g5 anyway my deaf one maybe
brother I don't know that's a bit tricky
okay I'm trying that one trying to be a
bit annoying with that night at least it
cannot go to age three as long as the
nidus damn ok and here well he might
have Knight f3 but mmm i can play Queen
f6 that's okay i'm not sure how stupid
it is Bishop h6 so this is actually a
move yeah that's me Knight f3 I can just
take a night f1 King g7 should be ok ok
so maybe just here Andrew cage area it
shouldn't be too bad have to be aware of
the time situation i'm quite clearly
behind not that I'm not used to that but
after that long break i'm not sure how
quick i will be if i need to be I mean
at least usually I am able to accelerate
quite quite quickly but
five weeks off I really haven't played a
single game of blitz chess in that five
weeks so completely rusty okay so this
means we're going to trade some stuff
which is fine with me especially as long
as I'm able to maintain that dark
squared blockade what is he thinking of
not just queen of three well Bishop
takes h6 that cannot be helpful am i
overlooking something sometimes I wonder
I don't think so I think Queen f3 is
just the most most natural move okay so
no is doing that what is the point
hmm what's the point rook h6 is he going
sure that's not going to work right I
don't I'll get it really does he want to
play with exchange down maybe this is
some compensation after Queen f3 but I
cannot really believe that okay this is
him this is probably not helping him
very much okay i can check check on g5
and then King g7 now okay let's start
with that are there's also G for hanging
by the way which I did not see in the
first at first mmm okay I can hmm Bishop
g4 queen of sourness can of it's not
really good that's not really good but
hmm should you fall gage one King g7 and
cats kind of a self-penned it's not
necessary let's just go here I mean
strategically speaking I'm not much
better really my dark square control
it's very helpful the bishop is on g4
anyway so I can do something like Bishop
d7 rook edge a Droog edge for and pick
that up pretty much at any given time
here yes also no calendar player so
thats it's nice Bishop 1c2 was not the
greatest piece now it wasn't a good idea
to trade everything off on age six I
think he should have been um played a
simple move that would have been much
better okay so it's up to off to an e3
yeah here Queen f4 is an interesting
move trying to yeah I think I'm going
for that good why not activating the
Queen and if it takes but you can get a
pair for my king up to f6 to e5
it's nice oh yeah we can okay it takes
could have retreated to the Queen and
here yeah g5 was my I think g500 I can
play look H form mmm okay wonder if hmm
if it helps them if he can play g5
himself sorry yeah let's go g5 and
prevent that not totally sure about this
but so King up to e5 would be great you
can try to regroup it's Knight to f3 but
i always have rook h3 controlling that
square so that is the next step you look
age three and March the King up to e5
also I can think about reroute in that
Knight to e5 that's also good oh it's
taking a long time here that's okay over
here it's not strictly necessary but I
maybe I should've played rook age for
him time whining but ok that's it's not
bad at all this way of playing should I
go f3
ok
now that looks nicer f3 I could be five
now it's not really speeding up that's
a-ok as CA he still has night f3 I
really I really did not appreciate that
to the fullest hmm okay I mean I can go
back to f6 but I really should have
played rock edge for that would have
been quite a bit better provoking f3
first okay I'm like I'm winning this on
time I mean I'm still better but I think
I could have been much better in
comparison okay so let's go back to the
critical phase of the game i think
around here White's position is
certainly okay as nothing really wrong
with this position Bishop here King g7
long all this is totally totally logical
I mean I don't think I mean in trouble
here really as I'm blocking blockading
you on the dark squares quite reliably
the computer gives wide a pretty big
edge 0.8 but i'm not sure i'm buying
that I mean what is there what exactly
is this why doing computer wants to do
this just to get an idea what what what
the engines point is I'm not quite sure
let's say and maybe it wants to take on
c5 this this could be an idea actually
like here taking no I was thinking maybe
Bishop c5 I avoids the computers move
okay
hmm yeah I'm not totally sure how good
that is I mean it gives 0.7 but I get
night f7 I mean it's a very it's a big
blockade yeah I came probably the
computer is right that right is bad i'm
not sure how much it is though what what
did he do inflate this move I think this
is already helping me out trading
trading pieces and he should just play
queena three I mean let's take that back
queena three I probably will take a
check and now yeah you can this is an
interesting moment maybe ft exam like
this and this and India I'm definitely
okay but it's not like I'm better why
while in the game yeah we had this
series of trades that's a bit slower
connection here we had the series of
child and my queen was coming in quite
quite actively I probably can take on g4
but I wasn't completely completely sure
like chaff to this this this okay have
Queen a furious MF queena form okay then
I should take the pawn yeah I was just
thinking okay I'm better anyway yeah why
should I take a pawn and I don't know i
mean here Luke h 8 i'm just in very nice
control him yeah like is some pretty
pretty much winning him okay oh I'm
missing this one yeah this is a nice
nice little touchy for engage one that's
even quicker but ok this is very good I
probably after here here I probably
should have played that move like f3 and
then continuing or like maybe even be
five is good activating this Bishop yeah
this is better than the game a little
bit at least I think like him b5 was
already a good move button okay I went
here
and now be five yeah blacks position is
still very much preferable but I could
have done without 9003 but you know it's
not just not doing that much I can go
back and it isn't it didn't help what
I'm still intending to take that pawn
and you cannot take it so I mean like
this and then going back over here yeah
compass on minus two which is pretty
pretty high score for the materially
equal position okay so that was a good
start here after this long break hope
you enjoyed the video thanks for
watching